le lycée c'est le fondement du reste de
vos vies parce qu'il faut pas se louper
sur la première impression qu'on donne
ici qu'il faut gérer les conflits mettre
du coeur et surtout n'entrez pas au
lycée si vous n'avez pas d'appuis il
faut vous vous seriez les coudes pour
survivre pigé une dernière chose
couchez pas avec mountain le lycée c'est
l'occasion se réinventer mama site des
changes la romance contre les cauchemars
les meufs est son barge
on
d'accord
il vaut mieux être loyal que gagner
comme pas
[Musique]
pitt et jolie dis donc et ça me plaît
j'aime bien les gens sans limite
[Musique]
tu sais pas c'est de rester tous les cas
ne crois pas cette vie c'est ma destinée
c'est trop tard
comment on va survivre au lycée
[Musique]
est ce que tu pourrais essayé de
m'expliquer ce qui est fait c'est
compliqué on échoue sa gelée remarquer
frais nas pertes et pas besoin de chance
on est à brentwood rien mal se passe ici
tout bio jay simpson
désolé jamal non c'est bon j'ai aucun
lien avec